the last words of villain utters before
their demise speaks
volumes about their character their
history and the story they came to tell
star wars is no different these are the
last words of
every major fallen star wars villain
darth vader or
anakin skywalker depending on your entry
point in the franchise
is as distinctive a villain as any of
pop culture's various bad guys
from the imperial march that introduces
him to the plot twist heard round the
world that defined him
to the prequel films that attempted in
vain to provide him with an origin story
it's hard to top the villainous
treachery of lord vader himself
after vader hurls emperor palpatine down
a massive shoot in the end of return of
the jedi
suffering fatal wounds in the process
were shown the true form of anakin
skywalker
a sad frail old man concealed under a
facade of cruelty and evil
anakin is content knowing that he's done
for but
luke insists that he needs to save his
newly redeemed father
anakin resolute responds you already
have
luke you were right you were right about
me
tell your sister you were right anakin
now free from the imposing mask of darth
vader has come to terms with the evil he
has perpetrated
and has no one but luke to thank for his
redemption
if darth vader was the vicious
force-wielding muscle of star wars
then grand moff tarkin was the sly
menacing brains of the empire's
villainous plot in a new hope
before the franchise expanded to include
a massive universe of media
one could easily see tarkin as the
primary antagonist of the death star
plot
even if vader's flashier more
aesthetically appealing stylings would
become the focal point of the series
villainy
it was tarkin who kept the trains
running on time his final line uttered
was a simple
but assured directive to his crew you
may fire when ready
if only tarkin knew earlier of that
slight design flaw in the death star's
core
which allowed one lone x-wing pilot to
shoot into that one
small exhaust port with ease perhaps the
most famous
question to come out of the original
star wars saga might just be
who shot first han or greedo if you're a
true star wars loyalist
you obviously know the right answer but
george lucas's many revisions over the
years have certainly muddied the waters
surrounding this most famous cantina
brawl
lest we forget the source of the
life-ending argument the rhodian bounty
hunter
set to collect payment from han solo on
behalf of jabba the hutt
han doesn't give up so easily promising
greedo he has the money
but it's just not on him at the moment
greedo's heard that one before so he
tells han
in her tease
which loosely translates to i've been
looking forward to this for a long time
and blasts him from under the table
ending the cat and mouse chase once and
for all
a sad last line for a sad bounty hunter
made even more sad by lucas's latest
edit
providing greedo with one more odd alien
utterance
mcclunky a hutch word that loosely
translates to
this will be the end of you in all of
the star wars universe's array of
colorful characters
no one might be more aesthetically
displeasing than the grotesque
slug-like gangster jabba the hutt one of
the most
feared crime lords in the galaxy jabba
makes his first on-screen appearance in
return of the jedi
though lucas would later edit him back
into a new hope in
far less imposing form set in his lush
palace among an array of equally
freakish alien criminals
is the way we prefer to remember him
sadly for us
jabba doesn't get a noble send-off line
before his demise
during the last clear line he simply
orders those beneath him to throw luke
skywalker into the dreaded sarlacc pit
put him in soon after that he's brought
down by the captive princess leia who
weaponizes the chains of her own
captivity to strangle her disgusting
jailer ultimately a less than noble
death for a far
less than noble alien mob boss a deadly
sets force for evil with a flare for the
dramatic
emperor palpatine's journey from a
creepy villain who pops up at the end of
return of the jedi to the ultimate
binding character of the entire star
wars film saga crept up on the culture
pretty quickly
which seems pretty on brand for a deadly
former senator
turned lightning throwing space wizard
it would have been all well and good for
the emperor
to remain dead after being cast into
oblivion by darth vader
but disney just couldn't leave well
enough alone
his final lines uttered while torturing
luke with forced lightning would have
been pretty apt
too you have paid the price for your
lack of vision
now young skywalker you will die of
course those no longer
qualify as palpatine's final words
thanks to the dark power of the sith
palpatine rose from the grave to lead
kylo ren into a new reign of terror
and to reunite with his inexplicable
granddaughter rey
in his final showdown with the hero of
the sequel trilogy
it seems as if palpatine has rey on the
ropes in his final attempt to consume
her and take her youthful power
he tells her you are nothing a scavenger
girl is no match for the power in me
i am all the sith fortunately for the
galaxy rey is able to summon the power
of
all the jedi and use it to finally
defeat palpatine
once and for all if any good did come
from the phantom menace and the prequel
trilogy
it was the fantastically designed new
characters and creatures
including darth maul the main antagonist
of the first prequel entry
his distinctive red and black makeup
devil horns and double-sided lightsaber
truly make him one of the series most
memorable villains while maul is
typically known as a silent
character he actually does have a few
brief moments of dialogue in the middle
of the film
he speaks primarily in conversation with
his master darth sidious
he says to him at last we will have our
revenge
this sadly wouldn't be true for maul as
he would apparently meet his end after
being cut in half by obi-wan in battle
it wasn't until much later that maul
appeared again during the animated
series
rebels where obi-wan finally defeats him
in battle for the last time
where he says of luke skywalker he will
avenge us
in its seemingly endless quest to
explain every single facet of classic
star wars lore
the prequel trilogy of course had to
answer the question burning in
everyone's mind
where did boba fett come from sadly the
answer appears
to be that boba fett is a clone in the
grand plot to create an army of clones
for the republic
django fett was selected to serve as the
model from which all clones would be
created
as part of his payment django received
one unaltered clone that he could raise
as his son
who we know is the one and only boba
fett
after a quick fight through an asteroid
field with obi-wan and the jedi mentor's
subsequent capture
jango and a bunch of alien bug people
catch up with anakin and padme as they
look for kenobi at the droid factory
here django captures them and brings
them to the fighting area on geonosis
saying don't move jedi take him away
upon entering combat in the arena later
on django loses his head to the purple
blade of master windu
in the elaborate plot to kill senator
amidala in the first act of attack of
the clones
senator palpatine tasks count dooku with
eliminating her
in turn dooku hires jango fett who hires
shapeshifter zam wessel
who programs a robot to send two deadly
worm-like creatures to kill padme
even with all this twisting and turning
to off the former queen
the plan is stopped dead in its tracks
by young padawan
anakin skywalker and his master obi-wan
after an exceedingly long and elaborate
chase of top speeders
across skies and through cd nightclubs
they eventually track russell down and
interrogate her
she is only able to muster up one hint
about who hired her
it was a bounty hunter car django fetch
puts a quick end to the shapeshifter
before she can divulge any sensitive
intel
her final words before dying translate
to bounty hunter slime ball
before his passing it was well
established that if you wanted your
sci-fi or fantasy film to reach epic
heights
you hired sir christopher lee to play
your villain the storied english actors
credits include the count
dracula and saruman from peter jackson's
lord of the rings
you don't get much more iconic than that
lee brought his sinister
booming voice and towering presence to
the star wars prequels
in the role of count dooku yet another
evil apprentice to palpatine
dooku proves a worthy enough foe cutting
off anakin's hand
and holding his own against master yoda
in attack of the clone's most
exciting lightsaber fight but it's in
the concluding chapter of the prequel
trilogy
revenge of the sith that dooku must
finally meet his maker
in his final face-off against a newly
revitalized anakin
dooku wielding his lightsaber as
confidently as ever
utters to anakin i sense great fear in
you skywalker
you have hate you have anger but you
don't use them
dooku knows more than he realizes as
anakin does let his anger and hate
overcome him
resulting in the gruesome beheading of
dooku an act that
certainly contributes to anakin's
transformation into the evil lord vader
it's fair to say that newt gunray sent
the whole prequel series in motion
alongside his casually racist voice and
his completely off-putting design
newt had the gall to go to war with the
planet of naboo
and become part of the separatist
movement that continued the escalation
of palpatine's plan for galactic
domination
so you could say that he deserves it
when he gets slaughtered by the newly
anointed darth vader
alongside his fellow separatists just
before his death he tries to plead with
vader
the war is over lord sidious promised us
peace we only want not good enough newt
he's cut off mid-sentence by anakin's
wrath it's fair to say that among the
many
many inhabitants of the star wars
universe newt gunray is about as likely
to be resurrected as jar jar binks
among the onslaught of new characters
thrown into the mix in the prequel
trilogy was general grievous
a secondary antagonist introduced and
quickly defeated in revenge of the sith
he was responsible for the kidnapping of
senator palpatine that kicks off the
film
and he serves as a catalyst for one of
the more exciting action sequences in
the film
a multi-lightsaber wielding duel against
obi-wan kenobi
he mocks him and the incoming troops
army or not
you must realize you are doomed
evidently not
it seems eventually obi-wan is
successful in grabbing grievous blaster
and
absolutely demolishing the squishy alien
remnants that lie beyond grievous's
hideous robot
exoskeleton in its wartime retelling of
the events leading up to a new hope
rogue one chronicles the completion of
the first death star by the empire
and the rebel plan to steal its
schematics in an attempt to destroy it
the mastermind behind the empire's plans
is orson krennic
director of the imperial military
department of advanced weapons research
and
enemy number one of all rebel scum
the final confrontation between krennic
and our hero jyn erso is an especially
tense one as ever krennic boldly
declares this victory
not only for himself but for the empire
at large
so all your ships in here will be
destroyed i lose nothing
but time you on the other hand
die with the rebellion as if
by fate at that very instant he is
struck by the blaster of cassian andor
and immediately falls dead in his tracks
you'd think these star wars villains
would learn to dial down the hubris by
now but
they never will it seems in solo
a star wars story we follow the rise of
a young han solo as he gains a lifelong
friend in chewbacca
meets his on-again off-again frenemy
lando calrissian
and flies the millennium falcon with
gusto
solo's wild lifestyle attracts nefarious
characters like tobias beckett
someone han almost thinks of as a mentor
until he betrays him at the worst
possible moment in their mission we
learned that beckett has been working
with the film's true antagonist dryden
vos
ultimately han and beckett end up in a
blaster standoff
and in traditional star wars villain
fashion beckett goes off
monologuing providing han the perfect
opportunity to plant a perfect kill shot
just before he goes beckett tells han
you made the smart move kid
for once i would have killed you i
really was gonna learn how to play that
valacord
this references his earlier dreams of
retirement from the life of looning and
thieving
dreams that will have to go to his grave
with him beckett did teach han an
important lesson though
be careful who you trust in this galaxy
in solo the main evil organization is
the crime syndicate crimson dawn
seemingly led by the previously
mentioned dryden voss
he only shows up a few times throughout
the film but it's ultimately revealed
that he and his partners in crime are
planning to use the stolen coaxium from
han's mission to support the growing
reach of the evil empire
even a scoundrel like han solo will not
let that stand
but vos is not alone in his plans as
he's assisted by the woman of han's
affections
kira whether han realizes it or not in
fact just before voss's ultimate demise
he tries to impart this to han
on she's done things that you could
never understand but
i do i understand her completely
once you're a part of crimson dawn you
can't leave
it's not long after this that voss is
stabbed right in the stomach by kira
making her the new boss in town finn's
journey from timid stormtrooper to
courageous rebel places him squarely
opposite his former boss
captain phasma the chrome-clad leader of
finn's
erstwhile troupe phasma is a notable
deadly opponent
the perfect physical embodiment of
everything finn despises about the
stormtroopers and
the first order in the last jedi finn
gets the chance to face off against
phasma one-on-one
just as the ship they're on is
collapsing after being struck by admiral
holdo's attack
just as phasma thinks she has the upper
hand finn strikes a
deadly blow phasma remains defiant at
the end
telling finn you were always scum
to which finn triumphantly responds
rebel scum
just before sending phasma to her doom
every star wars trilogy needs a demonic
villain sitting on a throne
pulling the strings of the other
villains preferably with the force
in the sequel trilogy we get the vile
supreme leader snoke
brought to horrifying life by the master
of motion capture himself
andy circus before rise of skywalker
revealed snoke's odd history as a clone
created by the emperor
he's just another in a long line of
puppet masters working their mischief
and chaos on
unsuspecting dark side abiding champions
of the force
with his claws sufficiently sunk into
kylo ren it seems all but assured that
he'll take over rey's mind in no time
in response to rey's efforts to turn ren
he says
you think you can turn him pathetic
child i cannot be betrayed i cannot be
beaten
i see his mind i see his every intent
yes i see him turning the lightsaber to
strike true
and now foolish child he ignites it and
kills his true enemy
you'd think a foe as powerful as snoke
would have
more self-awareness kylo does indeed
igniting his lightsaber and cutting
snoke in half in the process
with this act kylo finally becomes the
true villain without a master
at least until he's controlled by the
emperor in the next film
old habits die hard
in the occasionally subtle mirroring
deployed by the sequel trilogy
this series iteration of grand moff
tarkin shows up as the similarly
scheming general hux
similar to tarkin's relationship with
vader hux also seems to find himself
playing second fiddle to the forcey
machinations of kylo ren
hux meets his end at the hands of fellow
first order general pride
blasted for acting as a mole within the
first order and attempting to bring down
kylo ren
technically his last line is they
overpowered the guards and forced me to
take them to their ship
at which point he is blasted to oblivion
for his treason
earlier on when asked why he's
portraying the first order
he gives an answer that provides genuine
insight into his character
i don't care if you win i need kylo ren
to lose it just goes to show that within
the first order the desire for power
inventions will overtake
all else the rise of skywalker wouldn't
be a star wars movie if it didn't
introduce yet
another villain in the final installment
to add an additional layer of menace to
the closing proceedings
richard e grant entered the picture
playing general pride
a former member of the empire now
serving in the ranks of the first order
and palpatine
pride was one of many officers serving
as part of the empire back in the
original trilogy
and his reign of evil domination has
carried over to an entirely new
fascistic faction
one could say he's nothing if not
determined to constantly
serve the most evil forces in the galaxy
but
such devotion does prove to be his
undoing in the end
his last words capture the true power of
the rebellion
saying where did they get all these
fighter craft they have no navy
the answer an admiral tells him that
it's just people
when all is said and done perhaps the
best new character introduced in the
sequel trilogy is the twisted villain
turned anti-hero ben solo aka
kylo ren son of leia organa and
han solo ren sees a way to gain power
through the force
outside of the confines of the jedi sith
binary
his idolatry of his grandfather darth
vader proves to be his downfall as he
follows him down the path of redemption
after it's already too late
his journey is one of deep complexity
both in the way he reckons his own place
in the universe
with what it means to harness the force
as a skywalker
his final lines arrive earlier than his
death in a confrontation with his mind's
version of his deceased father han
ren admits to the specter of han i know
what i have to do
but i don't know if i have the strength
to do it dad we never get to hear
ren's true final words whispered to rey
but the novelization of the movie
reveals
what he said after slipping into the
netherworld of the force
i will always be with you check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about star wars
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you